what is it like negotiating for a
hostage with a kidnapper what is the
toughest part of that process
the toughest part is if it looks bad
from the beginning
and you gotta engage in a process anyway
what are the factors that make it bad
well that that makes you nervous that if
you're an observer situation where
there's General negotiation or it's a
hostage negotiation
what makes you think that this is going
to be difficult
if they want to make it look like
they're negotiating but they're not like
in the 2004 time frame
um Al Qaeda and Iraq was executing
people on camera for the publicity
and they wanted to make it look like
they were negotiating
so they'd come on and they say if you
don't get all the women out of Iraqi
women out of the the jails in Iraq in 72
hours we're going to kill a hostage
that was one of the demands in one of
the cases in that time frame
now first of all even if we'd have been
willing the US government Coalition
would have been willing to do that it
wouldn't been able to happen in 72 hours
so is it an impossible ask from the
beginning
and so then then that looks really bad
like they're they're trying to make it
they're trying to make it look like
they're talking reasonably and but
they're not so your hostages in bad
shape there if they've made a demand
that you just even if you wanted to do
you couldn't do uh so then what makes
that very difficult is in kidnappings
especially
you're working with family members
you're coaching people
bad guys are in touch with family
members or if they're not directly in
touch with family members the other
thing that Al Qaeda was doing at that
time was they didn't give us a way to
talk to them they make they're making
statements in the media but then not
leaving their phone number if you will
yeah
so that's one more thing like they're
intentionally blocking you they're
asking you to do something you can't do
they're not giving you a way to talk to
them
so you gotta get with the family and
discuss with the family how you can
approach things now the family
definitely wants to know is this going
to help there's a bunch of cases like
that in that time frame
and you got to be honest with them it's
a long shot our chances are slim and
none and when it's slim and none I'll
take slim but it's still very very slim
and there were a number of people that
were killed in that time frame before
the tide finally got turned and it was
it was hard dealing with the families at
the time can you negotiate in public
versus like a direct channel in private
oh yeah bad guys pick the media
they're making statements in the media
so and that's a big clue they're they're
a chant their channel of choice
tells you an awful lot and if they're
choosing the media then that means
there's people are trying to appeal to
that means in their view there's such a
thing as good media so if there's good
media there's bad media how do you make
it bad and we made it bad for them it
just unfortunately it had to go through
a number of iterations before they got
the message and quit
in that negotiation do you
think about the value of human life is
there a Dollar figure is there how do
you uh enumerate not enumerate quantify
the value of human life yeah that's uh
it's like Beauty seeing yeah the
beholder
so that was the first lesson on any
hostage negotiation really any
negotiation like it doesn't matter what
it is to you matters what it is to the
other side one of the things especially
in your in your conversation I listened
to with Andrew
um by the way you guys uh I I another
thing I really liked about that
conversation first of all I think the
world of him Andrew huberman yeah Andrew
and uh You released it on my birthday I
appreciate that that was a nice birthday
perfectly just for you yeah yeah nice
job thank you
but the empathy is in the eye of the
beholder
uh in every negotiation whether it's
over car a house
collaboration in your company with the
bad guys how does the other side see it
now the nice thing about kidnapping for
ransom if they're if there's an actual
Ransom demand it's an actual demand
is it's a mercenary's business they're
gonna take what they could get and they
tend to be really good
at figuring out how much money somebody
has so
and again I'll keep drawing business
analogies you're looking for a job with
an employer
there's a market price of the job
and then there's what the employer can
pay you
now maybe the market price of the job
Market's 150 Grand employer can pay 120.
but it's a great job you know we're
talking about Elon a minute ago
like I'd work minimum wage to follow him
around yeah you know that would be worth
it what are the value other than the
dollars
and how hard is it to get the dollars
and how quickly can you get to them
those these are all things that the bad
guys are good and kidnapping are good at
figuring out so
the value of human life to them is going
to be what can they get a crazy thing in
the kidnap business
we used to get asked by FBI leadership
when is this going to be over
and dance would be when the bad guys
feel like they've gotten everything they
can now dissecting that statement
you're talking about when they feel
like they got everything they can so the
key to kidnapping negotiations are the
feelings
the bad guys we're talking about
feelings kidnappers feelings
which drives everything doesn't matter
what human endeavor it is
so it's not a reason it's emotion
there's no such thing as reason